right ladies and gentlemen I believe our
IT system is once again up and running
so if we may now have the next
application please page 1 2 1 I think of
all on the same page and it's a hospital
ringing sure and so not possible present
the case thank you Thank You chair Thank
You members ladies and gentlemen as you
will have seen by the agenda item this
is a slight can everybody hear me yes
sorry something happened a slightly
unusual scenario of an application that
we can't actually determine today
because it's being appealed against
because of non determination so the
applicant didn't want to wait any longer
before we made a decision and has
appealed to the Inspectorate so we're
not at liberty to refuse or approve
today the reason I brought this to you
members is just to clarify the case that
we will fight at appeal and to ask you
to consider a couple of points that have
crept into possible reasons for refusal
the appellant has lodged their case and
has answered the substantive points I
put in my reasons for refusal as well as
addressing the two points which we
deferred this for back in July
just just to remind your foresight it's
it's an often of the built-in road to
the left there to thee to the east and
sorry to the west of often itself
outside of the built-up area boundary
and refusal is being recommended for the
reasons listed in the paper you have
received hopefully it's all coming back
to you now I want to turn to the first
reason for it being deferred that
related to the summer some case which
you've just discussed it was felt
possibly that were we to refuse the
often application and not mention
anything about highways issues that
might then jeopardize what we next said
about the summer some case that was done
on a precautionary basis but having gone
away and looked at it it's felt probably
that given the distance which I think of
quota is about two and a half kilometers
and more or less certainly over a mile
it might be pushing it a bit to
associate the two with each other and
had you granted approval can here now
yes something went off there again had
to you granted permission for something
that the whole matter would have gone
away quite cleanly I think probably
because some she was still being
discussed it's a bit less clean but I'd
still make the point that the distances
are so great that you shouldn't really
tie one to the other from often you may
get a dispersal of traffic other than
through summer shouldn't it certainly
would include so much room no doubt but
it wouldn't be just some sham and were
we to try and fight that an appeal it
might not be a very strong case
the second issue for deferral was
accessibility this had followed a brief
discussion about primarily wheelchair
access to one or both of the bridges it
wasn't clear from the minute whether we
were talking about the proposed new
bridge or proposed replacement bridge if
I could just remind members that part of
the proposal was to put a bridge across
build stone road from Bilson Road to the
development site itself that would have
been a motor and gone again
okay motor and pedestrian bridge and the
second bridge was also proposed which
was a replacement to pedestrian bridge
down in the gorge right okay going going
to the proposed bridge sorry about this
I mean it's very hard
can you hear me from there okay this is
the proposed bridge which goes from
Bilson road to the site so Bilson Road
just at the top there can you hear me
now yeah it will just keep dying doing
that what's tough to keep telling on
again so just just let's let's go with
that it goes on to the site you can see
the local stream which is locally known
it's the channel underneath there now
the wheelchair issue was brought up and
the paths that you can see on both sides
of bridge measure approximately and
there was some variation on the scaling
of the drawings 1.3 to 1.4 meters so
they are wide enough to take a
wheelchair that they're almost wide
enough to take a wheelchair and a
pedestrian passing each other but but
not quite you need about 1.5 from from
my reading the situation I stand to be
corrected on that so I would argue that
the new bridge as proposed does comply
with the standards for wheelchair use
and therefore the accessibility issue
there is dealt with there you go
approximately 1.4 right the other issue
was the new pedestrian bridge that was
proposed currently those who know the
area well will know of this particular
bridge which is buried quite deep down
into the surprisingly deep gorge for a
little stream like that I don't know
what's happened geologically but it's a
very deep gorge and the bridge you see
there is halfway down it the applicant
was proposing to replace it with a
better bridge but certainly one that's
still set down in the gorge it's it's
not going to be real chair accessible
realistically and to do that you'd have
to do either some complex winding path
or bring it up to Road level and I
understand that the the new bridge which
they are doing for the motor and
pedestrian access does cost six figures
plus so it's not realistic to ask for
them to do the same here some forty
metres along on the second bridge so the
advice might be to the applicant just to
not touch this one because it's not
needed for development it's just a an
extra
a sweetener if you want so my advice
members would be to do a way of the
reasons for refusal which could be put
on your reasons refuser which would be
those relating to accessibility and also
those relating to the Samsung issue so
that's it manager thank you oh yes the
reason for refusal is on page 1 to 2
sorry J I didn't go into too much detail
on that it's all about sustainability
and the you know with spatially opposed
housing in this location and therefore
that's why we were paving refuses also
there was in the show that affordable
housing which didn't comply of policy
and obviously the debate should today
probably just be focused on the narrow
points that I've listed but of course
members are free to discuss other points
that they wish but we can't prove or
refuse today yes so the recommendation
is on page 1 to 2 which would be the
recommended reasons for refusal and with
our debate today and the outcome of it
today will be a recommendation really
for the officers to see which way we
would have gone on this because of the
issue of the case being before the
inspector so if that's clear for
everybody
we do have a debate we have the
potential to debate and people have the
entitlement to speak so we need to
listen to have you've got some people to
speak please Colin Pinson Roxburgh who's
the parish council if you'd like to come
forward please thank you
oh good morning and thank you for
hearing us I speak I'm half of the often
relation parish council and our real
objection is that we totally do not
agree with this application for the
houses and we think it is totally
unsustainable we have already made a
presentation to you on the previous
meeting which I'm sure you all made
notes of but our biggest concern is that
it is can you just keep pressing the
buttons to make it come back on again it
is on it's on very high-quality
agricultural land it's in a sensitive
area for nature conservation we're also
in what's known as a dark area so any
new develop will being a light pollution
and the main impact that we have a
concern about is this is outline
planning and there's going to be a
massive bridge and no matter how you
look at it in our little village it is a
massive bridge so what the impact would
have on our village is unbelievable and
then we've got the extra traffic 32
homes you all know what that gives with
the figures that you can have find quite
available it would be a tremendous make
more amount of traffic there are other
offers of sweeteners a wood woodland
area the grazing area and also
allotments these houses they've got such
small gardens if they were more
separated and spread out we wouldn't
need allotments we as a parish council
we do not want the responsibility of a
grazing area and orchard and allotments
we think we we have everything we need
we have a lovely village hall we have a
play area there and we are happy we do
not need
thirty two homes which is labeled some
affordable I don't see owning affordable
about anything on this application on
behalf of the parish council we think
that they don't really look affordable
and we would just urge that you as the
District Council help protect our
village against this development and
that's all we have to say we oppose it
thank you very much for your time thank
you very much indeed does anyone have
any questions no I think you made it
very clear to us of your views thank you
very much indeed if you'd like to return
to your seat thank you we now have mr.
Kelvin moody who's an objector if you'd
like to come along than take three
minutes and bear with us with our
buttons if it goes off just keep
pressing it and we'll keep hearing you
[Applause]
first of guess it should have spoke
colleague first because he's mentioned
most of what I'm going to anyway however
I did make the presentation to the
previous committee so just what to read
to write some points really so first it
often has been declared Hamlet in the
job local planner 2019
this this application would be outside
of village set on the boundary which
obviously goes against most of the
planning policy framework it's too many
houses in such a small space it would
totally create overall village and it's
Colin rightly said the Nature Reserve
and stuff like that we have no reason
for because we've got a natural Nature
Reserve which should be left on spoil
we've got list of buildings in the
vicinity and we also have medieval
woodlands or which would become
endangered by building all these houses
boy from what I can see the new parking
plan which has been part of online seas
is incredibly short vehicle parking
spaces which you mean vehicles would be
parts all over the village again
something we can do without Colin also
made reference to the bridge this has
always been a big bone of contention and
we as residents are struggling to
understand how highways have managed to
to approve the visibility's plays
without having a deal a properly
designed bridge because bridge is the
design of bridges is is so huge that you
have retaining walls non retaining walls
and this would affect the visibility
splays apart from which they've yet to
come back to us on whether or not
they've actually done their traffic
survey in the summer someone the results
of their server online there's no
results for our traffic survey we
suspect to using four year old survey
for a totally different Road in the
village we also have a far more suitable
brownfield site which is less than a
mile away yes it has got an issue but
the issue there would be far easier
overcome what it would be to build 32
houses in an area like often the salt is
on greater agricultural land Park which
is floodplain and we have huge
unresolved issues with sewage because
we're not on mines drained
no matter what the reports say we have a
sewage treatment plant which is empty by
tanker and to put these houses in there
you would have to get your sewage from
the development to the present sewage
plant the only way to do that would be
to pipe it and it would have to go
through people's gardens all via the
channel again hardly fantastic and so
for those few reasons we've as residents
feel that this application should be
facing in its entirety and finally I'm
kinda surprised I'm not a planner but
looking at the recommendations from the
planning officer and why she refused
there was a lot of reasons what should
have been refused and they also they all
seem to be under one umbrella headings
were three sections to me that could be
watered down you can take pieces out of
that and possibly get round it to get
the application accepted at a later date
and I'll conclude there thank you thank
you for that does anyone have any
questions if you'd like to return to
your seat thank you
I think I've just sort of flagged
something up here on page one two three
the recommendation it says minded - well
it wasn't minded - it was a proposal so
we need to amend that - the proposal was
there we didn't we can't do that okay
right we now have the councillor daniel
pratt board member if you would please
and can we hear from you thank you Thank
You chair yes
needless to state say the stance of my
constituents has not changed the nature
of this application or any like this
would have a detrimental impact on the
character of the village and negatively
affects the quality of life for its
current residents the committee has been
minded to consider reasons for refusal
on the base that it goes against the
strand of socially social sustainability
or socially sustainable development
sorry in accordance with the NPP f the
proposal if it went ahead would see a
growth of around 20% of the village it
currently has 358 residents these 32 new
dwellings 26 of them have three to four
bedroom units so it would considerably
increase the population of optin green
the footprints in relation to the
village is proportionally large and the
plan itself kind of demonstrates what a
large expansion this would be for a
relatively small village in terms of the
NPP F framework and this being socially
unsustainable the village is isolated
and lacks public services and amenities
it's been highlighted many times before
that there are four buses going each way
in and out of Ipswich every day from the
lion burners but to only to pass through
the village the school is fully
subscribed so parents would be forced to
make additional car journeys to take
their children to school sumption school
has a capacity of 350 students and that
school is working at full capacity okay
I feel that it's important that the
committee is actually reminded of the
other material considerations and
reasons why this application would be
unsustainable and we are minded that the
if the traffic volume increases in
solution is dealt with in Diddley sorry
that the issue with traffic volumes and
summation was dealt with in the forum
application then it is considered dealt
with here I think what has passed it
sort of has implication and bearing on
this so I would actually just I
understand that statistically or
categorically this application and some
assume is considered separate because of
the distance of 2.5 kilometres between
them and the two should categorically
not be associated but it's which is
indeed the main employment hub of often
or one of the major ones and most of the
traffic will flow through summer shown
on daily commutes so this would have
this this would still have a residual
impact to the road network surrounding
often this development would have an
impact and of course often has its own
problems with accessibility
there are pinch points in often also
builder Stern Road has single lane
sections that are unsuited to extra
traffic from this development in
particular the section between often
church and Pali Road contains the
junction with the very dangerous pinch
points indeed there is also increasing
road closures in the area and I can't
tell you the exact frequency but every
it seems that there is no time at the
moment where there isn't a road closure
and traffic is diverted through nettle
stood or floatin on roads there even
more
unsuitable than builders still in
Ipswich Road itself okay
whilst we are minded not to cite the
bridge as a material consideration
against in terms of accessibility to the
site we feel that it is still
contentious the channel and correct me
if my figures aren't exact is is around
five meters
or more deep and construction and the
piling needed would cause unnecessary
environmental harm to the channel
causing erosion and changing the shape
of the bank and causing noise
disturbance during describe there's
construction and when it's in use I also
feel that we we haven't really given do
you concern regard to the concerns of
residents about waste treatment we're
still not entirely sure whoever this
development would have its separate
waste treatment facility or they would
just piggyback on the one that's already
there but in any case it would mean more
waste collection lorries driving through
the village and and this is a concern
that hasn't really been addressed
there's been no agreement with the
Parish Council on the adoption of a wild
flower meadow or community building and
the biodiversity aims of that wildflower
meadow are still unclear the site is in
close proximity to a triple si
Middlewood which so this development
would have an impact on that triple si
and finally I would just like to say
that the the proposal completely ignores
the housing needs of the village and
those housing needs are for properly
affordable homes consisting of small bed
one to two bedroom the dwellings thank
you very much thank you for that does
anyone have any questions
councillor Matheson means searching for
some time in in the revised agenda
papers which I think what did come out
with the main bundle but were separately
fixed that's why can pilot for a long
while
slide 19 I was able to find that one I
I'm sorry it's not slightly later on it
so it's like 18 is the one of the the
bridge from my memory that the section
that the section of the channel that's
shown just isn't that shape at all and I
wouldn't want us to be relying on that
of the appeal as as a valid drawing
frankly I don't know what you you would
like to say about it we can find the one
you've got the paper one yes I go UT is
it is it a question for the officer or
for the that's really difficult for me
to say I don't think it really captures
the dimensions of the channel properly
or the shape of it off by memory but I
don't know if I can I can clearly say
sorry the the drawing obviously for the
the bridge detail and it is the one on
page 8 so it slide 18 ultimately the
drawing of a channel which may vary with
regard to season and rain flow in the
area he's gonna be a very difficult
thing to do accurately to click the
accuracy should be on the bridge
necessarily what's way below underneath
it in terms of something that's more
organic and can change is that the the
issue we have here but ultimately I
think we can we can take it that that
channel could be very wide in terms of
its outflow but we don't know
just to pass a comment wouldn't that be
engineering works and in any case this
was sent in by the applicant so you know
it's illustrative I think John
ultimately would have been based on
mordant survey drawing in the first
instance not a detailed engineering
drawing of the bridge construction
I think we we're almost delving into the
depths if you'll excuse the pun off of
something that is beyond what we really
need to be doing but thank you for
pointing it out does any answer yeah
just a reinforce a point at least from
my memory of growing up there as a child
at the channel shape has not really
changed drastically in its shape or form
for 20 or 30 odd years my point is that
the construction of this bridge would
change the shape of the embankment on
that on that channel and therefore could
have an environmental impact yes I think
our officer would like to say something
Thank You Jay I just want to clarify
that ecology and the Environment Agency
didn't object and details of the bridge
would be part of an application anyway
right thank you very much indeed
so we now move to debate but we have got
to remember
yes I'm sure thank you
to kick this off really I would go to
page 1 C 3 which is a conclusion and the
recommendation 3.1 it talks about what
we should really dismiss in this matter
and what we should focus upon what
should focus upon is everything in 2.1
so bridge aside Road aside safety side
let's concentrate what's in 2.1 there's
nothing there to support refusal on this
application and and I'd point out things
such as cs2 and CFCs warmer it fails
that we already mentioned the
agriculture
and this is a terrible waste of really
good cooks LEM when we did the site
visit it was in full flow fantastic for
a field full of barley I think they were
really nice that's really important that
we still sustain food in this country
and it's not all about development this
development
cuts that site in two develops half of
it and then goes well here's some free
land that's not going to be used for
agriculture or use and there's no need
for it either because it says in CS 2
community services and facilities
meeting a proven local need well there's
no proven need for allotments there's no
proven need for grazing land because
people don't own sheep on estates
anymore so if there is no need so it
fails on that one as well we then talk
about the lack of affordable housing
absolutely right but a key bit on this
is overdevelopment sustainability and
the key that this is a hamlet so why are
we proposing that we accept a
development that almost almost increases
that Hamlet by 1/3 it's incredible
so why are we doing it so I think
there's enough substance in 2.1 with all
the right references to the right CS and
also policies to actually refuse this
bang on just two point one so bridge
aside gilli aside shape of the river
aside a road traffic aside it fails
before we even get to that point can we
have someone else who hasn't spoken yet
first please John anyone else wishing to
speak in the debate counts for
councillor Richardson thank you yes I I
agree with much of what caster Humphreys
has already said I think there's plenty
there in paragraph 2 point 1 that gives
a very comprehensive reason of why we
will be minded to to refuse and why the
appeal should be rejected there's not a
huge amount I want to say if you want
over this at any great length we've gone
over it Adam I'm at a lot of the
previous meeting I think we've all we
were all aware of what the issues are
but there is sufficient evidence
displayed in paragraph 2 point 1 so I'd
like to move that we accept the offices
recommendation
thank you very much anyone no cancel
Norris yes thank you I would like to
support the recommendation thank you for
that and on that does anyone else wish
to speak that we couldn't refuse to sit
on this I mean I'm not that we couldn't
refuse it have we got sufficient yeah
are we happy with this but bearing in
mind
highways issues aren't on here and we
don't need them at this point but it's
just a comment on making councillor
Madison yes I the the the description of
sustainability the reason you know is
very broadly written in 2.1 there are
quite a number of reasons why this is
unsatisfactory and I think that the
sustainability embraces them all and
that we really don't need to stick our
necks out on the highway access issues I
I agree with that so yeah thank you that
anybody else wishing to speak or I have
a proposer in a seconder before me can
we make a vote on this now are we happy
to do that all those in favor for the
refusal which is recommended as
described earlier yeah you know we are
unanimous wants to put the hand up thank
you very much indeed thank you everybody
so we'll move on
thank you very much indeed and we move
on now to item 7c please and Daniel will
make the presentation if you could make
your way quietly please
thank you
so Daniel Cameron will now present this
case thank you very much indeed
Daniel Thank You chair yeah we've got
before is an application for full
planning permission and for listed
building consent it's for the change of
usage version of Barnes to five
residential dwellings at basketball in
Batsford move through the presentation
we've got the site location plan just to
make numbers aware of the of the report
the key considerations are policy
conflicts between CSO one and CSO and
8:07
as long with CSO two and ho9 in as well
as paragrafix 79 at the end PPF impacts
on listed buildings in terms of
alterations to their setting with
regards to listed building consent we
obviously got the the special duty
imposed on us to consider the
desirability of the preservation of the
listed building and its setting and just
for completeness within the emergent
joint local plan although it would have
limited weight this site is not included
within the summit boundary we zoom out a
little bit from the previous map there
are a number of things just to note
we've got the green lines surrounding
the site that denotes the public
footpath network in the area we've also
got listed buildings we have fast at all
itself here just immediately to the
south that's a great - we have a number
of other grade 2 listed buildings down
here close to the church and the church
had listed it grade 1 in terms of other
constraints were in flood zone 1 there
are no true protection orders on the
site
we're not within a special landscape
area and they're not within a
conservation area if we come to the
aerial map you'll see broadly
surrounding bats football there is a
strong rural and strong agricultural
character if we zoom out a little bit
you can see this is replicated across
the the area so Basford just for you
know locational purposes is down
and then up here we've got the edge of
most high the application site is fairly
isolated from both but then in terms of
your policies with regards to barn
conversion along with sea so2 and
paragraph 79 tmppa we can make
exceptions for conversion of redundant
agricultural buildings and buildings
that would preserve listed structures
from considerations as to whether we're
dealing with isolated development in the
countryside in terms of the site layout
there are four buildings on site they'll
be converted to five dwellings and I'll
just quickly run you through them so
this pink area here would be building
number one that's identified on site as
an old grain barn building number two
it's just down here that's the orange
color it doesn't show up brilliantly on
the projection apologies that's the open
barn immediately to the north we've got
the old mill and then running down this
side of the site we've got a
single-story cart Lodge and that would
be converted into two separate dwellings
we have one here and then one here in
terms of elevation treatments I'll run
through these as well as the floor plans
and I've interspersed and photos of site
visits so members were able have an idea
of what what's their existing what's
proposed here we're by and large the
proposed drawings tend to keep the
agricultural form of the building intact
we've obviously got internal alterations
to allow for the residential use and
we've got parking provision provided
throughout so this is the grain barn you
can see that here you know there's a
small extension existing this is an
existing building designed to be or
proposed to be converted to parking to
serve one of the cartilage sites
this is the frontage of the grain barn
it's a timber framed timber structured
building mistake in agricultural and
then internal if you move on now to the
open barn
again the elevations deal with and
respect the agricultural fall of the
building and obviously again we've got
some internal alterations and you can
see here from the picture we saw earlier
this is that building closest to us
members that will become parking for for
one in the college's day and this is the
open barn internally again timber
structure building timber frames were
finished we've got some incidental
extensions to the to the building in the
form of this tin roof tin roof and lean
to come on to the old mill again
elevations are principally to treat the
building houses make some repair and
introduce features required for
residential conversion internal
alterations the mill and the open barn
are both relatively close to each other
when we look here this is the back wall
of the open barn this is the mill barn
so there's quite a tight relationship
between the two but in terms of the
elevation or treatment it's been looked
at carefully by the applicant in terms
of refraining from placing windows in
either elevation so there's not a case
of we're getting direct overlooking into
either
structure from either structure this is
the rear of the mill this and fiber
cement or or possibly asbestos on that
roof that we need to be removed as part
of the works in order to make it safer
habitation we now come to the cart Lodge
this green expanse members this is a run
of hedgerow intended to be introduced so
the cartilage is still on the other side
and I'll point to where that is when we
go to the ground floor plans and the
overheads and that would run just down
this section here and there'd be a split
within the
our Lodge so this would form one
dwelling and then this would form the
other and then this would set the edge
of that boundary for this property off
from the remainder of the countryside
and this is the exterior of the
cartilage itself this is if we quickly
flip back the next image is taking up
the internal of this portion of the
building again timber-framed and then
we've got the addition here in terms of
recommendation members the
recommendation before you from your
officer is for approval but I'll turn
things over to speakers and board
members and a lot of discussions begin
thank you for that do members have
questions at all
councillor Matheson yeah have you got a
picture of the two modern buildings
there which which were they so in terms
of this eye all the buildings are
curtilage listed so while they've been
tinkered with and played with as you
know the needs of the of the
agricultural business run from the sight
have changed none of them are
particularly modern in terms of their in
terms of their construction these are
all listed timber-framed barns we've
obviously got the this is a great
example actually this image you've got
the change between the pan tile roof
here and then the introduction of a
section of roof in this fibrous concrete
and that's all the last bestop's it's
been brought in your part of the roof
has failed and it's been you know
piecemeal repair and an extension as and
when when the need for the building
changes or when the opportunity to do so
arises which is characteristic of
buildings agricultural buildings and
then
thank you any further questions thank
you very much so we move on and we don't
have parish council objector or
supporter but we have the applicant
Jordan Marsh if you'd like to come
forward please thank you very much
excellent thank you very much and yes so
the the proposals are to convert these
unlisted but significant heritage assets
that fall within the curtilage of
batter's foot hall itself most of the
buildings are unused have been for a
while and so elements are starting to be
lost which is a shame
and there's no major economic use for
their repair be it from a commercial
standpoint and if we would go down that
route the influx on highways would
probably make that unviable as well and
the upfront cost of actually converting
them would be quite impressive the
actual designs of the proposals have
been informed from extensive extensive
research from the history of the
structures the development what is
significant about them and with the
local authority and conservation
themselves and we've taken an individual
approach to each part in its conversion
to highlight this as was mentioned
policy does support the retention and
conversion of historic assets and bombs
and we think this proposal does preserve
and in many cases improves the
architectural and historic interest of
the site as you saw there was various
and ciliary buildings that we would use
for cart lodges for garages for garden
shed stores so we're going to see an
influx of garden furniture and sheds
being erected throughout the site also
there was a number of barns that
actually were in quite a sorry state and
quite of poor architectural or historic
merit which we are proposing to remove
so there are a number of other buildings
on the site as well so we've just picked
the best of the bunch joist the proposal
we believe a low density in order to not
create a bad influx on highways and
highways have agreed with this as well
and also there was an array of ecology
ecological improvements that have been
specified by a specialist in their
report obviously
my condition but most importantly this
proposal would preserve these historic
assets now something to of the Barnes in
particular the grain barn and the open
bar a pretty intact the structure from
its
hold standpoint and date back to around
the sixteenth century
so these bonds are sat on site for 500
odd years and it would be a shame if
they were to be lost
so hopefully this proposal would improve
the outlook of Basford Hall as well on
the site that's pretty much say there
was one thing with the slides I must
mention though I believe some of the
photos and some of the drawings don't
actually correlate to the correct
buildings the grain barn and the open
bar and the meal there was a bit of
divergence between photos because a lot
of on the drawings the proposals where
there's overhangs for cars and where you
saw that overhang that was the overhang
we've just improved it or or made it a
people's table so yeah I didn't want
anyone to be misinterpreted though from
the drawings with photos
thank you very much does anyone have any
questions thank you very much you know
return to your seat thank you thank you
just so we have counselor
Daniel Pratt again please if you'd like
to give us your wall members view on
this thank you
sure thank you very much chair so in my
view I can really appreciate some of the
merits of this proposal which would
create five new dwellings and could
secure the future of a heritage asset
and potentially but I highlight
potentially bring about some net gains
for local biodiversity however I do of
course share some concerns raised by
bastard battis of its residents and
parish council firstly the balanced bird
as we know is a hamlet village with very
limited amenities and bus services I've
been told more recently that the bus
services are very unreliable and have
been cut part of partly it's almost
non-existent there is also of course a
huge problem regarding accessibility the
site has really poor connectivity it is
over two miles from the residential core
of the village and pub where straight
road intersects Bowl Road the report
itself notes that these that the
residents of these dwellings will be
especially dependent on the use of a car
which is not particularly in the
interests of promoting sustainable
living Church road is narrow with with
sharp bends and whilst highways do not
feel that do not consider that the
safety of Church Road is a material
concern residents in the area have
raised issue with the problem of
speeding cars and I think it's further
that their voice is heard on that the
committee should consider the experience
of current residents and the impacts of
increased traffic following the
development and development in rural
villages such as Batsford should really
strongly consider the needs of the local
population
first the parish council has conducted a
housing needs survey in 2016 which
highlighted the need for small
affordable housing and potentially
retirement bungalows which the current
proposal which consists of five large
dwellings just simply not fulfill this
development really provides very little
opportunity or Manatee value to local
residents finally i untie us at aside
that some aspects of this project which
include infilling of hedgerows and
installation of bat boxes could really
have a net gain for bats and reptiles
however I would I would like to know
what other reasonable enhancements have
been proposed by play services in their
ecology report Suffolk Wildlife Trusts
have cited that Hayes wood door mice
were recorded in several of the
woodlands and hedgerows on the boundary
of the site place services have not yet
commented on the impact whether positive
or negative the development would have
on the dormouse
I would also like to see suffered
Wildlife Trusts renewed opinion on this
as I think that it would carry perhaps
more healthy scrutiny so just one last
point there has been some perhaps in
this understanding or confusion amongst
some of my residents about the
designation of these curtilage buildings
as great - listed the basis of
permitting this is partly because they
would secure the future of grade 2
listed curtilage buildings however there
is felt that there is some ambiguity
over whether the listed status of these
built buildings is valid in their
isolation from bats at all and it would
just be really interesting if this good
at this point was clarified before
before permission is granted on these on
this basis I feel that the committee was
to do appreciate the value of this
application I feel that the community
should refuse the application until
these matters resolves thank you thank
you any questions
the counselor no thank you very much
thank you indeed right we're into debate
now maybe somebody would like to start
us off on with the great thing Katz the
Humphries so chair thank you so I think
this is an excellent proposal that sees
the almost the keeping of this historic
asset it's in keeping with the bar
conversions and smaller developments
that we've seen throughout the county if
we don't do this or somebody doesn't do
this those big those buildings as we've
seen already will fall into disrepair
they're not being used and therefore
they should be converted and actually
the policies allow that in fact cs2
supports it so I can't see that you can
turn this down in relation to church
then I'll drive along that road a lot
and I know the area as well I wrote so I
disagree that's my point of view I don't
see what you see and I don't see it that
busy and I've Drive along it at all
times of the day and during the rush
hour if there is one here Batsford and I
have no issues with the traffic so
that's my personal point of view on that
so I support the highways comment a lot
so I just think this is a really good
use of buildings that fall into
disrepair and it will maintain a
heritage asset which is an important
aspect of so that rural life so support
thank you very much chair and I agree
entirely I think this is a fantastic
application because it both preserves
these historical assets but I think
actually it can enhance them as well
I've seen many instances where former
agricultural buildings when they've been
restored and when they've been converted
the residential use can actually be a
much nicer asset than when they were
previously just in a state of disrepair
and I think although this is a personal
personal preference I think actually the
design of some of these converted
agricultural buildings is nicer than
some new builds and I think particularly
looking at the the number of dwellings
and their design I think that's actually
when we looking at
or communities Hamlet's like often say I
think it's much more preferable to
convert existing output agricultural
buildings rather than adding new builds
which is not in keeping with local
character and I think we've talked about
you know barn conversions there being
plenty of them and I think there are a
number of sort of precedents that we can
draw upon when assessing this when I
from my own experience I live in
northern little green in the sort of
western half of the district and we've
got we're a tiny little hamlet very
rural we have opposite where I live we
have a 15th century farmhouse absolutely
beautiful and it had that an IV was it
great to list it but it had within its
curtilage a number of former
agricultural buildings which were
converted which were that listed
themselves and were converted into
residential use and that was a brilliant
use of those assets because it preserved
them and ensure that for the rest of the
community they could derive a public
benefit from them so I think if this is
going to be going in a similar direction
than I'm I'm happy to support it as well
thank you Karen Anderson yeah I mean I
think in this case the the the
advantages are going to outweigh the
disadvantages and what I wanted to point
to was all right they're going to be
very vehicle dependent they're y'all
know that location as well and so I'd
certainly be looking that we wanted to
add electric vehicle charging points
onto the considerable list of conditions
and yeah the I wonder what do some of
the one on page 284 support for
sustainable development principles as an
informative why why could that not move
as knotch to be their best you know
their best endeavors at least is is some
required required of them we know these
these old buildings are difficult to
work with but nevertheless you know I'd
like to see those those two
Asians added but with with that I also
certainly that the what the war members
said about the the the you know the
ecology enhancements that we make sure
when the details being worked up by the
officer that that condition is a good
and strong one that delivers all the
things that the young the consult II and
the Suffolk Wildlife Trusts are looking
for but I mean I think with those with
those conditions added are I would be we
need to move approval with if that
wasn't what else I Humphries already did
I'm afraid on that one that counts so we
can't add that as a condition because it
would damage the fabric of the listed
building and that's why yeah in terms of
adding electric charging points I don't
think the particular concern with that
but in terms of a sustainable a scheme
for sustainable measures the question
has to be what will those measures be
now will those measures be a fabric
first approach will they be more
renewable in plants such as solar panels
air source heat pumps and other matters
that could make a fundamental difference
to the historic understanding of these
buildings and we are essentially trying
to prejudge that by that condition so I
would not want to try and impose of
those things on historic grounds and
causing harm to the dista building okay
yeah I'm not looking for particular
proposals but we we do I mean we we have
this as a fairly standard condition
without us being specific on you know on
other applications I'm not asking to be
specific just that the it is
demonstrated by the applicant that the
you know that they've done the best they
can and it might be that insulating the
floors or something is it's the best way
to not touch the fabric while still
making improvements but I'm happy to
leave that to the experts but planning
officer just come back on that to save
you late bring the point where we do
impose it as a condition it is on the
basis that there is a likelihood there
is a range of approaches that are
available when you're dealing with
historic buildings that are listed we
feel that that range of a bit options
are exceedingly limited on that basis we
considered the condition possibly to be
overly vague and unreasonable in that
context however if you wish to impose it
you can cast gold
thanks very much I think this is an
excellent proposal and I'd want to
support it as written in the report I
think the this gives us the opportunity
of preserving some heritage and in a way
I find the designs very sensitive to the
origins of these buildings and I think
now the benefits of this scheme usually
outweigh any harm so I'd like to support
it as I say as written
thanks if no one else has proposed so
far but certainly make that proposal
thank you very much
cancel the Norris then councillor
Richardson yes second it I don't see how
we can refer this application it makes
good use of existing heritage assets
which otherwise I'm just going to
deteriorate further I understand that
there
some issues from the parish council side
but overall I take the benefits of this
outweigh those so I am quite happy to
support this thank you for that council
Norris Council Carter looking for a
doubt sea ice I've seen a letter here
from the regarding age page three to
three and I believe it's in regards the
same thing where it's got a recommended
ation for refusal from Southwark
highways and am i mistaken is this it in
application it is just say old letter or
yes it is if you look at the next page
to the left of it it's been superseded
by true
my apologies ultimately sometimes we
trying to give you the entire audit
trail of what we've received in this
case probably best to have summed it up
we've it's page three to one that is the
final response having dealt with those
previous issues so apologies for the the
confusion there but we have resolved
that point since no it's confusing when
you're looking at one and then you think
where is it going
no it's easily done yeah thanks for
pointing it out anyway counselor warbles
so it's just another point of
clarification councillor Matheson how we
put points about the charging points
doesn't that's not included in the
proposal and would the proposer and
seconder need that in there for them I
thought I was precise in in proposing
acceptance of this thank you as a point
of knowledge can you not just plug
electric cars into your own property is
that something there are five properties
here having spent time with relatives I
do have an electric vehicle but don't
have an outdoor electric vehicle
charging point yes can so just for
clarity so in such an area you could
quite comfortably plug it into your own
things right okay thank you for yes
counselor
yes thank you and if I may and it's not
debate it's only a question you can't
enter the debate okay here's a question
okay can we okay in that case well if I
remain the debate I think you're
on treading on dangerous ground because
the committee of already's that have
made a proposal and a second there's a
question but regarding conditions as
potential conditions yes okay I will
have to really rethink it a little bit
but okay I can make this a question on
conditions given that the the opposition
from local residents wasn't due to the
volume increases in traffic and thank
you for your rebuttal councillor
Humphreys it was on speeding could we
not include as a condition more
stringent speed limits on that road
[Music]
changing the speed limit of a road would
require traffic regulation order that is
in the control of the Suffolk County
Council's highest authority and equally
that would require consultation and it's
not a guarantee that it would go forward
and on that basis that is outside of the
control of the planning authority all
right so I have a proposer in the
seconder that we accept the
recommendations as written all those in
favor please vote and cancel its after
council accounting it and then those
against do we have an abstention thank
you great so we now need to move on to
make sure that we have the listed
building consent and this is the correct
way to present these cases whereby you
have the application and then we have
the listed building consent with the
same application but we need a separate
vote on it and Daniel if you'll just
give us thing it was not much to say but
you know he needs to tell us what we
need to know know some details for this
application are as shown in in the
PowerPoint and in the report provided in
terms of impacts on listed buildings
historic England and fairly necessary to
comment regards to the grade 1 listed
Church and comments from your own
heritage team
works up between the applicant and your
consul tees such that they're able to
give a recommendation of no harm to the
traffic of the characteristic buildings
or to the setting of the great two
buildings so we don't have any arm
identified and again the recommendation
is for approval of listed building
consent for the change of use and
conversion of the barns and that is on
page three four five so yes counts the
gold simply I would like to propose
approval the recommendation
and no I don't have anything further to
say only just some clarification on the
status of the grade 2 listed curtilage
which do seem to be separate at least an
ownership from Batsford hall itself
so in terms of the listed building it's
battered Hall itself that's listed it
great - this the setting in the
curtilage of the listed building sort of
differ from listed building to listed
building but in effect it comes back to
the relationship that that building
housed with it's setting in its
surroundings by and large Barford Hall
was originally you know quite grand
farmhouse set in this royal setting
surrounded by these open fields and then
over time we've had the imposition of
the over the barns on the date at which
a building is listed protection under
that listing extends to buildings within
its within its curtilage and for the
purposes of this application if those
barns are within within that curtilage
if we were in a situation whereby a
building is listed and then modern
agricultural buildings were created
within its curtilage well they might be
within curtilage and have an impact on
its setting but they wouldn't benefit
from that curtilage listing because they
weren't there at the time of listing
that's okay may I just very quickly add
to that it won't you've listed a
building if there are changes to
ownership at a later date those changes
to ownership make no difference to the
status of the list of building thank you
well I had cancelled Gould sort of had
his hand up first when I saw the first
invited rather prematurely followed by
councillor Humphreys and countess the
Richardson so in that order please just
repeat what I tried to say before I
apologize to the committee for being a
bit previous a bit just to recommend
approval but sure thank you it's just a
certain that approval I was going to
propose but I I wasn't quick enough so
until you notice thank you very much
indeed ladies and gentlemen thank you
and right okay we'll just have a short
break
very short break
you
leave rather urgently so if we can
perhaps resume our meeting
thank you very much so we move on to the
final application if we can please and
that is on page 377 and Daniel yet again
you're going to present the case for us
thank you very much thank you sure we've
got before is an application for full
planning permission for change of use
and conversion for bonds to for
dwellings a listed building consent is
not submitted with this application but
the reason for that is that the listed
building consent was granted under
reference DC 19mm 810 when the
application was previously considered in
regard to items to bring to the numbers
attention we have had an additional
neighbor objection received on the 30th
of September that's held on the planning
file and it refreshes their previous
objections which are already noted
within the report I also know that the
objective is is here to speak so if
there are any specific items they wish
to bring to your attention I'm sure
they'll take the opportunity to do so we
go through the application here we have
the site it relates to four bonds close
to Greenwood farm which is it in itself
a great tear listed building and some of
the barns in this case were actually
listed in their own right so as we move
through the presentation I'll take you
through which ones are listed which ones
are curtly to the student which ones are
modern in terms of considerations in
terms of policy we have the conflict
between CSO one in the countryside
location age of seven which restricts
creation of new dwellings in the
countryside against paragraph seventy
nine of the MPP F course strategy policy
two and local plan policy ho9
which allow an exception for conversion
reuse of redundant agricultural
buildings and for reuse of listed
buildings to secure their preservation
in terms of the joint local plan again
this site is outside of the settler
boundary for any
within the drunken match so in terms of
the listed buildings we've got Greenwood
farmhouse itself which is listed great -
we've then got the barn here and also
this Bullock house which are listed in
their own right
we've got barn number two which is
considered to be curtilage listed
we've got barn number three which is a
modern barn and then we've got barn
number five which is a again a modern
outbuilding in terms of the triple-s I
know it on the site that refers to
midfield meadow hey man I don't just to
the northwest and I'll point that out
from them which when we go to the aerial
maps as well in terms of other
constraints we have no public
rights-of-way through the site we have
no special landscape area affecting the
site no tree protection orders on the
site and we're not within a conservation
area again the site is located in flood
zone one so again note though for the
rural character and the agricultural
character of much of the surrounding
surrounding site if we zoom out a little
mick field meadow this is located a
short distance the Northwest up here
in terms of the map and the connectivity
from the site the site is roughly in the
center here we're about four point one
miles from Devon M where 1.2 miles from
midfield
and we're three point four miles from
sadhana basketball so in terms of this
site there are five barns on the site
but only four considered within this
application we've got this one here
which is barn number one which is the
listed barn
we've got barn number two which is the
curtilage listed barn
we've got barn number three which is a
modern barn here we have barn number
four which is a modern Dutch style barn
with open sides and then we've got barn
number five here I just in the bottom
left of this screen we've got the
redline outline here in terms of
alterations we no longer have this
connection to these grain stores here
members and the door shown at the back
of this Nissan huh are no longer shown
within submitted plans so that within
the redline plan because it comes right
up to the back of the listen up we don't
have those doors opening up into into
agricultural fields in terms of site
visit this is just barn number one
numbers and these are the proposed
elevations for the conversion and
there's some additional extension to
this building but in terms of
consultation with with heritage offices
that content with the detail shown in
terms of you know renovations and then
in terms of the the internal there's a
large structure within the building to
remain as void so there'd be no first
floor inserted here and that would be
used to display some remaining
agricultural equipment located within
the barn and to make a feature of those
for the understanding of the building in
terms of 3d you can view that void
better here in the roof has been taken
off we have mezzanine and the mezzanine
floor but then we have this void here
going right down to ground floor
in terms of the other barn this is barn
number two this is the curtilage listed
barn you can see the greater farmhouse
just beyond in terms of the elevation
treatment we have them here and then the
internal arrangement
this is barn number three it's quite
clearly a modern barn just from its
change in material constructed after the
listing with the surrounding area
a more modern treatments been proposed
for for this one to reflect the fact
that it's not a listed building so that
we'd still be able to visually identify
the change in age between the structures
it's much simpler approach here and then
we've got the internals and then we've
also been provided with the 3d
perspective of barns one two and three
just bar number one get your barn number
two on number three and then we'd have
the Dutch barn number four remaining
on-site there just for Korea this is the
the site visit image of of barn number
four and you can see looking almost the
other way we've got barn number two and
then through those trees behind you can
see a little bit of the listed farmhouse
this is barn number five we've got the
outbuilding and then we've got the grain
silos immediately adjacent to it and
then here we've got the elevation
treatments again more modern there's no
connection between the two and then
we've got the the Nissen Hut proposed to
be converted to a cart Lodge within
within that
if we come now to one of the the items
brought up by the objectors in terms of
the the access through the site this is
made along a narrow single leg country
track so this is the access facing north
so you'd have connection to deafen and
this is the public highway members
coming up here and this is it going
south this is it or anyone here again
you've got the strongly expressed rule
of character but then if we turn I can
see the access here and I'll show you in
the overheads as well members so there's
a a neighboring property accessed close
to this Junction here and then this is
the connection through to the site and
just from the site visit this is the
view back from the barns back along that
access road so in terms of the aerials
we have a neighboring property here
adjacent to the public highway and then
we have the access track running down
here we then have it turning the corner
just off screen coming up coming past
another neighboring property and then
continuing up here come to the end
continuing up here to access these barns
here the recommendation in front of you
again is one of approval members and
I'll stop my examination now and then
things over thank you for that and can
you just put up a slide to the one I'd
love to call it the jigsaw piece it's a
lovely piece just showing as the the
area
and it's a good review of all the other
bits that's helpful but yeah that wasn't
a fine yeah that well the other one the
next one actually um in the indent
there's a rectangle what's that
that's the Dutch bar and that's the
European side is which isn't included
within this application and it gives
that open aspect of it yeah sorry I
misunderstood that earlier thank you
very much it's only a game councillor
Richardson yeah can I just ask what the
reason was for the removal of the link
between bond 5 and the grain silos was
there any particular reason for that in
terms of previous applications on the
site we previously dealt with an
application for conversion of all five
bonds to dwellings but offices at the
time felt that the conversion of barn
number four and the addition to the
grain silos in barn number five weren't
acceptable and that application was then
refused we then dealt with another
application which was when the listed
building consent was granted that
removed barn number four but left the
connection into the grain silos and it
was officers and determination at the
time that that would likely not result
in in a dwelling that was acceptable in
terms of you know in terms of utilizing
those grain silos as internal
residential space any further questions
just from the committee no and then we
have our board members you just would
like to ask a question please counselor
morning yes you mentioned that you'd
received a late paper from September but
it's not in the pack but in the lake
papers you've got my board member
calling which isn't late because 27th of
June so what's the reason for not
including that paper and have have the
committee being able to look at that and
see what
well there's a reason for late papers
Susie's counselor Morley's calling paper
was put in the lake Titus I can answer
that one it's because it wasn't in the
paperwork and I said we need it so it's
unfortunately termed Lake papers but
that's that reason and then there's
another letter that's coming from an
objector and you with Alice at that
point yeah on the first point that was
an oversight with the part with regards
to the calling from the board member so
that was a mistake upon our path from
which we apologize generally though we
do not put the entirety of late
representations within table papers
they're summarized by the office if they
have come in I believe Daniel that it is
on the planning portal dough so it is
available so it has been published and
is available to view online if so if
members did wish to choose to look at
that but it we do not generally put in
late representations in their entirety
if there is a material change I believe
that would be reported to the committee
even the material change in the office
to the officers decision-making process
that would be what that would be worthy
of being reported to committee but if it
does not then it is reported verbally by
the officer
I think Thank You June and couldn't you
just go back to the map and can you
highlight the relationship between that
and the field house and the access
because the track at the field house the
land on either side is owned is not in
the applicants position Norway's track
is only one point eight meters wide it's
not required for safety
thank you so yes so if we go back to the
access so as I as I understand it and
I'm happy to be prompted otherwise as I
understand it part of the access here is
owned by the applicants part of the
access up here there's then a portion of
the access here which is owned by Field
House and then the remainder is owned by
the applicant so yes or in your papers
members you'll have a representation
from Suffolk Fire and Rescue in which
they state their requirement for a three
point seven meter wide minimum wide
access tractor to new residential
dwellings which is required within
building regulations so it's something
that the applicant will need to show
adherence to or deal with the relevant
section of building regulations that
deals with where that access is not able
to be permitted sorry janta so in terms
of in terms of the report
we could have widening here you could
have widening down here but the owner of
field house is indicated that they would
be resistant to any widening of the
track at this point on the land within
their ownership and potentially you
could also have some widening down here
but the real pinch point would be in
front of field house in terms of
representation from the highway
authority they've made mention of an
alternative access that could be
achieved without taking traffic past
field house and in exploration of that
I've asked that condition be added such
that prior to commencement on site we
get details of which access is to be
provided so they've been properly
secured it nice that should it be coming
right questions for the officer we have
counselor concert counsel Humphries and
then councillor Madison please MacArthur
thank you
well we haven't gotten to her officially
yet I know it was a point regarding
choice between she's facing you
I can't they'll file can hear the
answers from the officer I'm missing out
on half the conversation I don't know
what the questions been in because I
can't hear it which is facing you so
it's just the point
regards stats I think these it gets you
have to get used to speaking into them
and speaking up don't use so yeah point
taken thank you I'm sure cancel Molly
and move her and iPad and she'll make
adjustments right now they so we had was
that your your main issue at the moment
and then you'll hear the debate as it
goes forward for more questioning right
thank you
so counts the hunt freeze question for
the opposite I'm sure thank you and two
questions really the first question is
the hard fencing that the fire and
rescue services allude to will it
require MC reverse more than 20 meters
to turn around or not that's the first
question so in terms of highways
responses they've also required that a
turning actually provided at the
dwelling so into
of coming down we would have capacity to
turn swellings they've also asked for a
passing point to be created but in terms
of the actual sort of the width we would
need that widened to three point seven
meters at minimum partly and secondly it
actually says that the road should not
be less than 3.1 meters in width through
pinch points such as gates now this is
where it gets done specifics what is a
pinch point is it gate or is it
narrowing of a road and I think that's
quite a critical point so in its clarify
what the legal I think definition of a
pinch point is so you can answer this
question I think in the building ranks
documents the minimum is three point one
through a gate I think we have to take
the building Mike's documents as we are
there in the it does need to be a gate a
wider area might be difficult to learn
justify I think in would it also be
prudent to sort of mention at this stage
that any civil dispute is exactly that
and providing things can be overcome I
don't know what's your view on it please
from a legal point of view we gone -
okay so the County Council's
Fire and Rescue
have given us obviously a consultation
responses in your papers and they have
set out a criteria that they would apply
in terms of the building regulations
that would I as a separate authority to
ourselves now ultimately we could just
sit back and do nothing about that
because Building Control would have to
pick all that up anyway however we have
in this case I'm beginning to wonder
whether we should have done actually now
but we have in this case sought to get
details on various aspects of that that
includes the turning area and the
fencing as well in that regard and I
suspect the reason we've done that is
not because of a highway safety matter
but because of a reason to
ensure the historic setting all these
buildings is appropriately detailed
that is where I would stand on this at
the moment we have one access hosed not
to is that correct and ultimately if
there was a private civil matter in
terms of the access being available in
accordance with his application then the
application goes nowhere that would be a
private civil matter for them to resolve
if there is a ransom strip by default
they've signed up to that's their issue
that they're gonna have to sell
privately and they'd have to come back
again to come in with a different access
and different arrangement for you to
consider
[Applause]
no that was helpful yes thank you
and so did that answer your question
sufficiently yeah councillor Matheson
thank you yeah thank you I um yeah I was
that last points helpful out I did
wonder how an alternative access could
could be magically conditioned you know
if it was fundamentally changing the
application but I think that John's
saying that it it would be a new
application if it was a new access yeah
that's all right
yeah it would have been helpful to have
a blue line plan in the papers which I
couldn't find on this is green and then
the third thing really on page 379
masseurs comfortable with the the parish
is pointing to the to this Cermak field
meadow sssi and naturally england
they're saying they they have no
objection
presumably they know about the sssi and
and have taken that into account
that's the designation that they'll
they'll look after yeah so that they're
aware of it so the fact that they've
they've not objected it says to me that
there's not an impact any further
questions for the officer
and we don't have the parish council but
we have an objector mr. Barry Lee if
you'd like to come forward please thank
you and when you get settled if you
press the button and then you have three
minutes thank you
before a start
Daniel's description of the access road
is quite incorrect so I'd like to
address that afterwards well you've got
three minutes I've prepared this new
information well sorry what is the new
information we've only got one access
road and we're debating on the one
access road you've ever got anywhere to
describe what is public highway or the
extent of the highway is what the
bottleneck well can we just sort of move
on I I think you have three minutes and
I'm sure the board member will have
taken and we've read your late report as
well but this was new information today
so if you'd like to take your three
minutes and tell us the information now
and then we'll review that yeah thank
you
just quickly our understanding is that
if certain information is required to be
given and if that information is not
given because the details are in correct
or incorrect or misleading then section
s three to seven a must be offended
that's the Town and Country Planning Act
there is misleading errors and
information in the documentation
especially regarding the second access
route which does not exist and also
proposed reduction in agricultural
traffic they are missing confusing and
contradictory documents or plans in the
application the next issue is access to
site there is no access to the site we
own the land on either side of the 8
meter section of private tract which
does not belong to the applicant it will
be hard finish to 2.8 meters wide which
is too narrow for the fire service who
require 3.1 pinch point this is a curved
road as well also too narrow for
construction traffic there is no other
access to the site has suggested on the
agenda
the full fire and rescue response report
has a number of serious issues
preventing the ability to attend fires
some are unsurmountable the 450 meets a
singletrack highway is in regular loose
use enormous agricultural vehicles if
the existing road were to be used the
massive increase of private service and
delivery traffic would inevitably lead
to delays and confrontation activity on
the road cannot be seen from the active
deck napkins sight and no amount passing
faces on the private 280 meter track to
the farm would mean confrontation on the
highway section there's no turning point
a field house so many of our deliveries
have to reverse the full 450 metres of
the public highway finally the previous
two applications were refused on issues
that we have not changed daniel stated
in his refusal application number 2 that
the application is considered to be
largely identical to the one considered
before number 1 barn for has been
admitted from this application however
bond 3 and barn 5 remain within the
application no information has been
placed before the council to suggest
that the conversion of these two
buildings would not amount to a rebuild
as previously considered therefore it is
proposed to reach not proposed to reach
a different conclusion in this case the
application is recommended for refusal
and it was refused barns three and four
failed the hibbott threshold and would
result in substantial rebuild their new
builds plan planning of their fall now
recommended grants in contradiction to
the first two results and nothing has
changed only for the for the worst
because the salt has been reduced from
point eight hectares down to 0.5
hectares avoiding the affordable housing
contribution of 76,000 pounds but within
the documentation is fully anticipated
to go for planning from the
on armed for in other words that bond
for that's cut out he's going to have
planning permission on it and that would
take it over the threshold of affordable
housing so there's every intention and
you know conclude you're coming up to
your three minutes so if you'd like to
finish your sentences there's no there's
no justification for the avoiding this
sustainably it's just saying you believe
the sustainability issues I'd like
everyone really to read section four
because section four one two three and
five one two three four and five give
every single reason why you shouldn't
build these as particularly the three
modern bonds which are not there's no
structural surveys in this latest
application for any of the modern bonds
I'm sorry you're really going to have to
finish it been well over the time yeah
well I'm the chair and I haven't had any
further explanations but at the moment
you will find there may be questions
from the committee that might help your
cause so if you just like to sit there
and see what questions come your way and
I'm sure the ward member will be
speaking as well so if you would please
questions for yes
councillor Richardson apologies if I
miss this during the officers
presentation but could you just clarify
what these are not the papers we've been
given there's a great two listed
building just outside the area being
considered for this planning application
can I just clarify is that a residential
building and is it currently occupied at
the moment there's a six bedroom great
realistic farmhouse which is not part of
this application and is not as far as
you know intended to reveal or refurbish
it in any way that is fairly close to
the grade ii listed barn one and then a
curtilage bond
and there they're in a fairly close
proximity to each other yes just just a
confidence it's it's not currently
occupied that dwelling for the last 20
or 25 years it's been occupied by one
person and when the farmer died after a
few year then there's one person living
there
that's the humphreys mojo thank you and
that one person that's living there does
he use the same access route that we're
talking about he does use the same
access roof he probably goes comes and
goes from the site 3 2 or 3 times a day
and I have a couple of questions
you mentioned farm vehicles going up and
down there yeah was inching math but
what they come from and where they're
going - are they related to this side
no the farm vehicles are owned by a
farmer that farms to the south but all
the land around the whole farm
he's leased to him so he comes along the
450 meter access road and then just
before air house he peels off down to
the side there so can I just stop you he
doesn't come past your house of the
ownership of the bit of land is that
what you're telling me he doesn't
currently because there's a gate across
the prevents them thank you but I've
qualified there the person that used to
own the farm has retained a right
through the gate and round the side of
the site not the site at the 16 acre
plot where the site sits so that she can
get to her land if ever she needs to not
across the other farmers land that's
just
safety thank you and just before you go
I think John might answer issues yes
might have a few things there might be
another question as a results if you
just like sit tight
good answer first water dope Daniel
could put the plan block plan on the
screen because it might be just helpful
just to clarify what we're talking about
as we talk so there was a few issues
after that mostly referencing the
previous refusal now just looking at
that refusal and apologize if it's not
been detailed sufficiently within your
papers it effectively referred to Barnes
free and five for the most part and
essentially we'll start with number
three if you can free is the no the
other one that'd be a tough time that's
the one that's been removed from this
scheme so they sit that way around is it
also you just so just again number three
is right the refusal which referred to
Barnes three and five was referring to
which two buildings so in terms of the
first refusal in terms of barn for and
then burn five those are the two barns
the replicate there in terms of the 2019
refusal under DC nineteen to blow 809
there were reasons for refusal related
to DC barns we've had alterations to the
design of the two barns within this
application such that I don't feel it be
or my recommendation is that the design
has been changed and updated to reflect
more why we be coming from in terms of
our policies and the design of the
buildings in terms of my recommendation
or it is acceptable now so apologies
again for the confusion of numbering but
ultimately the position for my office
the officers are concerned is that one
of the offending bonds has been dropped
the other two have been altered
sufficiently that we feel that they are
considered appropriate now for
recommendation of approval
therefore moment that's incorrect no I
appreciate there may be a difference in
that judgment and terms of a subjective
judgment but that is the position the
officers have made so with the
information that we've now got does
anyone have any other further questions
for mr. Lee at all so if you'd like to
return to your seat thank you very much
indeed and we now have the act
contagions
Ramraj finally please thank you very
much
thank you very much for listening to me
I'm acting as applicant agent for the
applicant this application obviously
concerns for Barnes to those obviously
historical and one of those is listed
the second one would be considered a
heritage asset both normally considered
more than capable of being converged and
converted presidentially without too
much of a date of debate and obviously
you've just approved the last approval
on the same merits the two second ones
could have been obtained residential
planning committed conversion through
the class queue requirements and
originally we applied for all five barns
however it was felt that the two modern
barns developed beyond the limits of the
class queue requirements dropped we now
modified the to modern barns to limit
the changes that we're proposing within
the class key requirements so we were
reutilizing the existing building we
utilizing the existing frame so it
wasn't a rebuild it was sat within the
class Q requirements however what we
wanted to do was include the curtilage
of those barns more successfully and
allow the planning authority to control
those curtilage is obviously within the
setting of a listed building and within
the setting of a listed barn so that's
the reason the smallest of the bonds
with the grain silos we had originally
intended to do that as a three-bedroom
unit but obviously within the class q
requirements involved in extension which
we took off and planning authority was
then comfortable
should a class queue application be made
it would have been successful but the
ability to include the garage and the
curtilage around the building was felt
more beneficial one of the main issues
obviously as it's been debated about the
access the access gate is about four
meters if not a little bit wider than
that and historically it would have
taken all the farm traffic and obviously
it could be a potentially working farm
if it was restored into its farming use
so all the wide vehicles and machinery
and everything else would be able to go
on to the site without a problem we are
proposing to do some passing places
along the drive to enable vehicles to
avoid the need for vehicles to reverse
or anything like that and allow cars to
pass fairly comfortably without causing
a problem but obviously with a
residential conversion the vehicles
using the the access would be limited to
cars generally speaking obviously there
would be a construction phase deliveries
and that sort of thing but they're
nowhere near the onerous effects of
combine harvesters tractors and trailers
and everything else that could
potentially use the site at the moment
if it was a farm use we therefore
believe that the the modern barns are
capable of being converted under the
class queue but the planning authority
are able to make additional constraints
as well but not much
obviously with without doing the class
queue the planning authority are allowed
to make further conditions and
recommendations which would you know
enable us to enhance the setting of
elicitor buildings thank you for the
benefit of some of the newer members of
our committee perhaps our planning
officer would just like to explain class
q I know what it is but I think it might
be helpful and also members of the
public to understand I don't mind which
one of you does it but I know about it
but could you just give them could you
just give our committee and members of
the public just a little update on class
Q is falls under the permitted
development effectively it allows
something called a prior approval
process as opposed to a planning
application for the change of use of a
building to form a dwelling essentially
to summarize it there are less
considerations in respect of the
consideration of that type of
application there are restrictions to
what can be put forward under that type
of application but essentially it is a
reduced form of planning permission
there are you know there are reasons to
say that some barns can be converted
using that class q process and that is
often considered to be a material
consideration in the determination of
applications as well normally we
consider it to be material if there is a
class Q in place in the first place not
before so just before you know ask mr.
Wong not not filing your questions we've
got that cleared up so that you know
what a class Q is it just helps save
asking the questions through so
councillor Humphreys question for sure
thank you of course you've got a go in
the moment I thought it's an important
question to ask and I look at your
redline plan and look at the buildings
to look at your door access in and out
of those buildings and I can clearly see
that the door access in and out of the
building's
protecting the large and a cot remember
the numbers e buildings but the the
particular one we've got the dining room
the door pretty much opens up onto the
red line and that's replicated on the
cot remember to build in the square
building on the south and also the one
that's attached to the silos and my
question is this what's the design
reason behind that and secondly how is
it ever going to be available for use
being practically and I know I don't
haven't got the gist
is on this but I can visualize it feet
and maybe inches away from the door to
the red line which is outside the
settlement area of this particular
development plan I don't understand it
and I really understand it actually I'm
sorry I'm missing a point people make it
clearer so um can you bring up a slide
please that shows the red line plan at
the site we'll start with that one so if
you look at the top right hand building
the one with the little dining room it
comes out to right hand side can you see
that yep those doors that open out
double doors actually open out onto the
red line which is right almost almost
touching the building I find that
completely odd well then go down to the
building at the bottom of the screen we
get the same situation there with the
doors on the bottom side that open out
onto the red line as well and then we'll
go into the building with the silos and
the top right-hand edge there where it
meets the track again there are doors
sorry just to write the track there are
doors on the main building that again
open out onto the red line and that
seems odd to me
I love done this for quite some time a
lot of time actually that there would be
a distance those doors to open to close
because surely you open the door to go
and access the outside well how can I do
that if I'm banging on the red line and
I just want to know what the reasons
were for that and that's where we were I
like to come back on that because that's
the objects made a really interesting
point about fordable housing and the
size of development sites and by moving
that red line you've actually come in
just in to negate the need for
affordable housing so you can see where
I'm coming from I've got this doubt it's
going on my head and that's why I need
that clarification from you as to why
everything's so close the affordable
development the affordable housing
development doesn't normally kick in on
bond commercials simply because of the
areas that concerned point of
clarification on that because I don't
think this is a true bond conversion for
all of them because two modern buildings
owe to rebuilds
so I think actually I know
get legal advice on that now actually
that's perhaps not too true well I might
be wrong it's not a trueborn conversion
right first of all clarity from my
officer but ultimately we are looking at
them van conversions in all cases aren't
we not thank you
we're not looking at rebuild the the
doors on the back of the lease am huh I
believe have been removed from the
scheme so they don't apply and in
respect of the other openings I think
there was at least a metre boundary
between the end of the the door window
to the boundary that has been expressed
is that correct as well fit at least a
metre of land so you won't be stepping
literally out onto land it's not part of
this development let's get real though
if I can put it that way I don't know
that sounds too young for my generation
but ultimately yes there was a game to
play here in terms of the size of the
area versus how to avoid the council's
affordable housing policy in this
particular case I would stress that what
we have to look at if we're trying to
connect up the dots with the affordable
housing policy is how likely it is that
each one of these could come forward as
a separate application and how are they
independent of each other in this case
I've got an existing access that
effectively goes through the center of
the site which can be used independently
not through not from having to go
through one site to another
so I admit I think this has been
slightly coherent Clanny altered to
avoid that particular policy on the
other hand I can see alternative
applications that come forward in a
different way that would avoid it anyway
there'd be nothing we could do about
that so on paper it is not offending
that policy I agree there is a degree of
restriction to the area to avoid the
policy on the other hand as these are
bargain versions if that restriction
means I have less domestic activity
outside less trampolines and other
equipment lying about the countryside
then in many respects that mystery
perhaps possibly a favorable one but I
can only leave it there and let my good
members judge accordingly further well
thank you my chair story put me on the
spot it's my point I needed to make it I
do have to leave for work and if you'd
accept my apologies but I do need to
leave please enjoy everything babe thank
you thank you for that counselor and
again for newer members maybe they're
not really aware but it's not 0.5 then
the affordable housing games thing and
this is not point four seven enters so I
think that's where councillor Humphreys
was coming from yes there's an extra
point being added so you just reminded
me by telling me how much the the land
if the issue here nor point five
initially for affordable housing to kick
in it we've been 10 or more dwellings it
is only in the last year that it's
dropped in terms of the threshold naught
point 5 and that is because of the NPP F
and its definition of what is a major
development the NPP F curiously regards
major developments as nought point five
or more hectares despite the legal
definition of major development being
ten or more it is a conflict we don't
understand if I'm quite honest and we
will see where government goes in terms
of looking at that in due course but
because of that change in the NPP F it
has meant that we've had to review where
our affordable housing policy kicks in
and we're currently on the legal
understanding of Nohr point five or more
in land terms if there aren't any more
questions for mr. robb maus finally can
he return to his seat thank you very
much indeed if you would like to thank
you very much and now we come on -
counselor Suzy Morley if you
please thank you and if you can fellow
down the Thank You chair as someone who
converted and lives in what was a
derelict thatched barn in the middle of
a field
I'm very positively disposed towards
this type of conversion as it saves our
heritage from falling into disrepair and
being lost forever however my concerns
are not around the development itself
but the access to it the residents of
the Fieldhouse are able to observe the
firm movements and they can time their
journeys to and from their property onto
the public highway visually deliveries
and the postman usually have to reverse
back out onto the highway and the
increased traffic and agricultural plant
especially when harvest of 135 acres is
taking place with movements every 15
minutes
having the pass resulted in vehicles
meeting face to face and one of them
having to reverse several hundred meters
on to back out onto the main highway the
estimate of 12 extra vehicles on this
site for these new new properties or
what it will become new properties is
perhaps an underestimate there is part
of the private track which is about 8
meters long that is only 2.8 meters wide
and cannot accommodate the Suffolk Fire
and Rescue Services requirement from
minimum access for emergency vehicles in
order to reach the listed building as
re-access
some tree prone access for emergency
vehicles to reach the listed buildings
and other conversions this is a pinch
point where the land on either side of
the track is owned by the fieldhouse who
are not willing for this track to be
widened unless the applicant can access
the public highway by a route other than
via the fieldhouse track then I do not
see that this application if approved
can ever be delivered as the condition
cannot be satisfied there is a
suggestion that
turn to your axis can be made however
that is not included with this
application
I'm extremely encouraged by the
provision of about of a barn owl as
stated in the final paragraph of the
ecology section but again I can't see
how that can be delivered either I'm
presuming it's a barn owl box there is
also the potential for the impact upon
the sight of this Site of Special
Scientific Interest nature reserve of
Wingfield Islamic field meadows in
summary I like the development itself
but unless an alternative access can be
provided I do not see that it is safe
for you to approve this application
thank you before I go for questions to
the ward member can I just ask so that
we can be clear is there a physical gate
on privately owned land that would
restrict the fire engines from getting
through number one is there a
restriction there that would stop a fire
engine from getting through I'm not sure
I think the gate is on the farmers
access right but the it's a maybe I may
be wrong on that it's the physical with
restriction width restriction by field
house that is the issue not not the size
of the gate not the fact that they're
engaged a price right the physical size
right thank you for that counsel does
anyone else okay
councillor Richardson thank you mind
sort of a question and a request for
clarification as well so this is one of
the reasons why I asked about the other
listed building that's just outside the
area that we're looking at this six
bedroom farmhouse if there's currently
not keeping to that who's using this
same access what would happen currently
if that person needed
the fire services support I don't know
there are this is the difficult balance
of judgment because ultimately there is
an existing situation for a neighbor of
the birth of the site in terms of their
current highway arraigned well access
arrangements that could be argued to be
in conflict with the current
agricultural use or current residential
use of the site and we've just heard
that they are forced to deliveries are
forced to his return to the highway to
turn around and so on just thinking
about this a little bit one part of the
recommendation on the existing access
route is to have passing spaces agreed
there's no reason why those passing
spaces cannot be both before this
cottage which is the neighbor and after
so therefore by default of putting
parking spaces to solve hopefully some
of the issues of the new development and
mitigate its burden the resulting
benefit would be the existing property
could make use of that in terms of
having a a passing space before their
property at their disposal by default I
they're not connected as such but that
is a possibly consequential benefit if
we do ensure that the parking spaces are
both before and after the existing
property but that is just a suggestion
if we wanted to mitigate up so I alter
our planning condition accordingly that
we are recommending thanks for that John
um I'll ask councilor Morley this
question but it may well be needed to be
deferred to somebody for an answer but
the small bitter that could you put they
take it off me and put the the access up
for us please which would be more
helpful
the access there's a photograph of the
driveway or something right on the bend
on the road or something and cancel em
all you'll be able to help me
keep going
possibly there there right so am I right
in thinking cancer morally that on the
left is the access to this development
and to mr. Lee's property believe so yes
and is that jointly owned or is there
just a right-of-way over it for both
parties are you aware I'm not aware of
that but I do know that the land on
either side of that tract is owned by
the field which is why I don't see how
passing places because it would eat into
somebody else's land
somebody must have right of access up
that line to get to mr. Lee's property
and to the further properties
still a would you be prepared to just
answer that question for me please to
help the committee is the the the piece
of road there that we see going towards
your property do you have a legal right
of way does everybody have a legal right
away or do you both own it concurrently
just that bit there public highway
so can I just ask one further question
so presumably the council would repair
that should there be enormous potholes
etc etc that is public highway yep thank
you but you don't own it personally
there thank you thank you for that thank
you thank you thank you very much yes
councillor Richardson this is
questioning now for cats l'amore
honestly that's could I just get that
slide back up again because that's the
bit I wanted to just ask clarification
on yes as I understood it during the
officers presentation it was the landing
before the fieldhouse it's the other one
to the right do you want the other one
Novak that can do because it's part of
the same bit the land to the right of
the access road before the fieldhouse is
that owned by the applicant
where it says imagery yes that field
yeah I'm not sure that so I understand
that in terms of ownership for the field
house it's this stretch of road with the
land either side so fur and then the
land here I think is owned by the
applicant I think that's the thing that
blue line and the field above it who
owns the field above it no to the right
stop is that also in the applicants
ownership this one I'm highlighting or
this one is my understanding that
they're in the ownership of the
applicant okay thank you thank you
right have we asked all the questions of
the ward members sufficiently thanks
very much councillor
so we
not one
go on counselor Matheson open it um I
think the there hasn't been much
discussion about the sustainability of
the location and that is actually quite
poor all things considered it's it's
it's not even near the public public
highway I let alone anything looking at
a bus route or a foot way and nothing
like that at all
which and there's no there's no
affordable housing benefit so I think
the to be to be turning into dwellings
the modern the modern buildings as well
I thought I can't see that that
satisfactory accommodation you know and
public benefit is good it's going to
result from this which outweighs the
difficulties of its location so I I
think the officers have made clear that
you can convert a modern barn provided
you don't increase increase the
footprint of it or change the structure
of it but nevertheless it doesn't look
like a very satisfactory idea I think
that there's been hints about contrived
size of the site as well and all these
things together don't encourage me to
overcome the sustainability issue
[Music]
the policy background to your
considerations comes from the local plan
in the first instance which allows for
rural development of redundant bomb type
buildings it doesn't actually have
anything in there that talks about the
age of the building it just refers to
redundant buildings and on that basis we
have historically across large areas of
it Suffolk aloud barn conversions in
very remote and isolated locations from
barns to become dwellings now
traditionally we were very much into
traditional timber frame buildings would
regard to that policy but of course with
the NPP F and class Q provisions that
have come forth in the last few years we
have had to open ourselves up to far
more modern building conversions be
redundant barns that are a lot you know
perhaps a less merit in architectural
terms again would regard to Class q when
it was first introduced your council
your officers sought to refuse virtually
every single one of them on
unsustainability grounds until the
government decided to change that
criteria insure that we couldn't do that
and we are now left with simple matters
such as highways and ecology flooding
and other bits and pieces but ultimately
we have been reduced in perspective the
robustness on that issue we also then
have the MPP F and policy a paragraph 79
which does allow again for the reuse of
redundant buildings and encourages them
to be used for dwellings and there's no
provision within that to consider the
sustainability in fact it actually
pacifically says that the only reason
you'd allow for isolated sites such as
this is if it was a barn conversion and
on that basis I would find it hard to
defend a position of refusal on
sustainability grounds given our own
policy national policy and
material considerations anyone else
going to speak yes can't walk thank you
all right thank you Jeff
I was confess I agree what counsel of
Molly was saying I when I first saw this
application had quite a bit of
enthusiasm for it is actually sort of
preservation of two listed barns
preservation of a traditional curtilage
of another listed building
I like their notion of the retention of
the silos and then it's not as part of
that and that sort of agricultural
heritage of the site I thought it was
really very interesting however though I
was confused when I read through it
about this business of the access and I
think this is really muddied the waters
for me I feel is it the nearest neighbor
is the field house and I think this this
is it we need to take into account their
position on this that the access should
be resolved at this stage rather than as
a condition I don't feel the I could
really support the proposal unless it
included the access as well and I
welcome your comments and I concur with
them actually and I - when I saw it I
wouldn't normally jump in but it's
having a bit of difficulty to sort of
get the conversation going and I thought
with fabulous designs and so on but I
wonder if maybe the best way to direct
the committee today would be to possibly
don't defer this for some sort of
resolution
and mr. Lee alluded to the fact that
there's a new access being brought
forward well it hasn't really I think
it's just been alluded to
and so I wonder if we could defer this
and get some sort of clearer resolution
on this so that mr. Li can have comfort
that if there is an alternative that he
wouldn't have to live under the stress
that he's clearly under at the moment
the use of the bones and everything is
fantastic to sort of put these modern
things in place
I hear what councillor matheson says but
again sustainability if it was a cue
scheme you know it would have come
through so can I propose from the floor
that I can defer this yes so I propose
that we defer this because we want more
details on parking turning passing bays
and I will add to that any alternative
access and then we've got to ensure P
1086 for safer safe and suitable access
to the side to be achieved for all users
so I think that's my recommendation
councillor Norris happy to support you
firmly clarification on the heiress's
thank you very much councillor Carter
was next councillor Matheson
turning circle of entry into a building
for Motability vehicles and for
wheelchair the current access it with a
redline it doesn't allow for returning
circle before a wheelchair to actually
into a building I think that's a fair
point would you be happy I'll add that
to it I'd be happy for that would you be
happy for that councillor Norris thank
you so without further ado with oh is it
necessary yeah I was just just slightly
concerned we're not we're not going to
get into into another room appeal for
non determination situation or what we
may do but that's the way we've got to
go we can't judge that no because I
don't feel like I want to refuse it I'm
asking for a deferral that's my personal
view and I'm getting nods from the rest
of the committee so so I think it's
always better to work with clients and
with objectors rather than going down a
straight road if you don't want me
saying so all those in favor of my
proposal for deferment on that basis
please vote we are unanimous thank you
very much indeed everybody thank you and
so that I was just going to say I've
soaked I might get my prompt he's very
helpful there are no site visits and so
I can declare the meeting closed and
thank you for everybody's patience thank
you